et cette invite aujourd'hui c'est vous
bruno cautrès bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau merci d'être là vous êtes
politologue chercheur au cevipof nous
sommes à moins de nous sommes à six
jours maintenant du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ici en france
dans une semaine à la même heure nous
serons qui a été qualifié pour le second
tour de cette présidentielle un français
sur quatre ne sait toujours pas à
l'heure où on se parle pour qui voter ça
fait près de 10 millions de français
indécis de ce constat bruno cautrès
découlent plusieurs questions d'abord
comme on l'expliquait est ce que ce
chiffre là ce constat l'a fait de cette
élection une élection très particulière
c'est une action particulière à cause du
contexte mais c'est pas si particulier
que ça pour expliquer cette incertitude
il ya des explications de très long
terme ça vient de loin depuis au fond
toutes ces dernières années l'idée que
les citoyens votent par devoir civique
est une idée qui est en recul c'est
toujours la conception dominante du vote
en france les gens disent en majorité
voté c'est d'abord un devoir de bon
citoyen meilhan deuxième modèle qui a
paru dans notre vie politique
un vote plus optionnel plus intermittent
on vote il ça vaut le coup on vote si la
campagne est intéressante une deuxième
explication c'est l'explication de 2010
est gérée l'élection d' emmanuel macron
a introduit une très forte perturbation
dans notre système politique partisan il
ya beaucoup de points de repère qui ont
volé en éclats et beaucoup d'électeurs
notamment centre gauche centre droit
sont un peu perdus troisième explication
il ya tout contexte de cette élection
bien particulière la guerre en ukraine
et puis aussi cette élection qui arrive
après une succession de crises et gilet
jaune l'aco vie de la gare de creil ça
fait beaucoup beaucoup d'électeurs sont
un peu en situation de confusion et nous
ce qu'on observe au cevipof c'est
qu'habituellement on n'a pas loin de 20
25 % de personnes qui nous déclare que
c'est dans les tous derniers jours qu'il
fige leur choix électoral ce qui fait
que ce qu'on appelle la cristallisation
termes techniques qui
parle du ce moment où les scores
semblent se figer et plus tard que
d'habitude et on ça ça me met quand même
les intentions de vote les sondages un
peu en fragilité c'est clair que ça met
beaucoup de pression sur tout le monde
savait de la pression sur les sondeurs
parce qu'évidemment c'est très difficile
de mesurer précisément les intentions de
vote mais il faut toujours rappeler à
nos téléspectateurs que les intentions
de vote qu'ils voient publiées dans les
médias sont sur les français qui se
déclarent certains d'aller voter mais
c'est vrai que ça a introduit un peu
d'incertitude supplémentaire et tout le
monde se pose certain nombre de grandes
questions la grande question c'est est
ce que l'un des candidats peut souffrir
d'une abstention qui seraient plus
élevés qu'en qu'en 2017 et tout le monde
a en ligne de mire évidemment une
candidature particulière celle de marine
le pen parce que là de se les assises
sociologique dans les catégories
populaires mais c'est en même temps dans
les catégories populaires qu on
s'abstient un peu plus par rapport à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
fait qu' il y as peut-être de moins en
moins de français qui perçoivent le vote
comme un acte citoyen est ce que là sur
ce point là il ya une fracture
générationnelle très nette considérable
très grosse fracture générationnelle au
fonds pour les plus anciens pour les
seniors on va dire que le vote du cf
toujours le modèle du bon citoyen il
faut voter rappelons qu'en france
pendant très longtemps
les catholiques par exemple était
d'efforts
participationniste on disait un bon
catholique c'est quelqu'un qui vote qui
participent à la vie de la communauté
dans les jeunes générations ce genre de
valeur sont beaucoup en recul il ya
quelque chose qui s'est développée dans
les jeunes générations qui est l'intérêt
pour la politique est très important
chez les jeunes la chose publique les
quais grandes questions de société les
intéresse beaucoup par contre il va pas
forcément dans le vote le meilleur moyen
d'exprimer leurs opinions est-ce que les
indécis d'aujourd'hui vont être les
abstentionnistes
dès demain en partie oui les
abstentionnistes se recrutent en
particulier dans les catégories
populaires mais aussi en dehors des
catégories populaires dans ceux qui
trouvent que cette campagne n'a pas été
très motivante et on a même une petite
catégorie d'électeurs français qui sont
très intéressés par la politique mais
justement qui considèrent que la
politique c'est trop beau pour être
confiée d'une certaine manière à la
campagne électorale que la campagne
électorale ne donne pas l'image d'une
belle politique d'un beau débat d'idées
et on va trouver même des
abstentionnistes qui finalement sont
intéressés par la politique la
présidentielle en france pendant lequel
l'abstention était la plus forte corrigé
si je me trompe c'était il ya vingt ans
en 2002 qui a vu pour la première fois
qualifié l'extrême droite au second tour
c'était le le père de marine le pen
jean-marie sk qui à qui profite à qui
coûte aujourd'hui une abstention qui
serait aussi forte ou alors c'est la
grande question qui est pas forcément
simple à répondre on va dire que
l'abstentionnisme normalement pénalise
les candidats qui ont des assises
populaires mais il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui dans les milieux
populaires par exemple si je prends
l'électorat d'eric zemmour ou celui de
marine le pen et surtout celui de marine
le pen qui a vraiment des assises
sociologique forte dans les catégories
populaires c'est en même temps un
électorat que très grande motivation de
voter ils sont très en colère ils ont
envie de présenter emmanuel macron
l'addition en particulier pour une
partie d'entre eux des gilet jaune et
donc cette motivation de vote elle peut
venir contrecarrer la tendance un peu
naturel a davantage s'abstenir dans les
catégories populaires on a entendu de ci
de là ces dernières semaines petite
musique d'une campagne électorale qui
n'auraient pas eu lieu ou qui auraient
été
particulière c'est certain mais en tout
cas qui auraient été minorée par rapport
à des élections précédentes si on met de
côté l'ukraine qui à juste titre s'est
imposé dans cette campagne comme un
thème d'actualité est ce que c'est
réellement qu'un est-ce que cette
campagne a été minorée et qu'est-ce que
ça laisse présager pour la suite c'est
le fait que cette pardon c'est que cette
musique et existe c'est clair que cette
dernière ligne droite de la campagne
elle est totalement la vue l'espace
médiatique totalement occupée par la
question de la guerre en ukraine alors
ya eu des hauts et des bas dans cette
campagne à l'automne ce a démarré très
fort avec la dynamique zemmour avec la
primaire des écologistes avec la
primaire de la droite et on avait vu à
ce moment là des thèmes comme
l'immigration la sécurité l'identité
nationale qui était fortement apparu et
là il ya vraiment une campagne à ce
moment là et puis il retourne là
qu'ovide et une nouvelle épidémie une
nouvelle vague pardon de l'épidémie et
puis ensuite la guerre en ukraine et
c'est vrai que la succession de ces deux
éléments à empêcher la campagne de
vraiment se dérouler on n'a pas eu de
grands débats entre les 12 candidats
emmanuel macron fort de sa position de
président de la république adiba la
tradition c'est que le président d'un
public est hors champ par rapport à ça
or évidemment débattre avec mais
emmanuel macron et était un élément
absolument décisif il a un bilan à
présenter
donc il ya eu une campagne qui a été une
campagne en demi-teinte et le fait que
cette thématique de la campagne en
demi-teinte soit paru nous réserve
peut-être des lendemains un peu plus
difficile parce qu'au lendemain
l'élection présentielle le vainqueur ou
la vainqueur tout le monde à lui dire
mais alors est-ce qu'un consensus existe
autour de votre projet autour de vos
propositions de réforme et c'est vrai
que c'est une nouvelle problématique
dans notre vie politique comment entre
deux élections créer du consensus créer
de l'adhésion autour des principaux
projets de la forme mais est ce qu'on
peut craindre
réellement que des rivaux des perdants
de l'élection
conteste plus ou moins fortement
l'élection ou la réélection de l'un ou
de l'autre il ne fait pas de doute à mes
yeux que parmi les perdants certains
sont des mauvais perdants c'est à dire
en disant j'ai perdu parce que j'ai pas
pu défendre mes idées à la loyale
emmanuel macron s'est dérobé si ça
devait être lui qui était réélu ou en
tout cas voilà on va voir ça sans aucun
doute mais on n'est pas du tout en
france dans le contexte qu'on a connue
aux états unis aux états unis on a connu
un paroxysme ce contexte c'est à dire on
a vu dans une très grande démocratie le
perdant de la présidentielle qui
finalement disais j'ai pas perdu or la
base de la démocratie et notamment de la
démocratie libérale c'est que le perdant
admettre sa défaite
parmi les petits candidats vous le
disiez on a entendu certains manifester
leur frustration de ne pas débattre tous
ensemble une question sur ces petits
candidats précisément qu'on appelle
petit car a priori ne dépasseront pas
les 5% lors de cette élection est ce
qu'il s'agit d'une tradition française
et première question et deuxième
question est ce que paradoxalement ils
sont petits mais est ce qu'ils ne sont
pas ce qu'ils ne bénéficient pas de
cette tribune incroyable qui est
notamment ce temps en ce moment de
campagne officielle lorsque pour les
petites formations politiques l'élection
présidentielle c'est un rendez vous à ne
pas manquer à ne pas manquer peuvent pas
manquer ce rendez vous parce que il ya
une particularité l'élection
présidentielle elle n'a qu'une seule
circonscription l'ensemble de la france
et donc pour de petites formations
politiques qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens qui ont pas beaucoup de
ressources budgétaires qui ont pas
beaucoup de militants l'élection
présidentielle une fois tous les cinq
ans ça permet de se visualiser ça permet
de rappeler aux français que ces
courants d'opinion existe et il existe
dans notre dans notre pays et puis
effectivement les règles de la campagne
électorale en ce moment l'égalité du
temps parole offre à ces formations
politiques à leur candidat d'un seul
coup une très forte visibilité et
d'ailleurs il ne s'en cache pas beaucoup
parmi ceux là 10 20 mois je veux pas
être élue je cesserai jamais élu par
contre je veux ré expliquer aux français
les idées et je veux montrer aux
français qu'il n'y a pas que les
candidats qu'on voit tout au long de
l'année est ce que il y a un vrai
rapport campagne prêt pour la
présidentielle réussie jeu message sans
jugement de valeur au 15 mai par exemple
fabien roussel dont on dit qu'il a quand
même été un peu une des surprises de ce
de cette campagne qu'il s'est révélé sur
une ligne d'ailleurs assez particulière
le candidat du parti communiste est ce
qui vient vraiment un vrai rapport
mathématique entre une campagne réussie
sans aucune chance d'être qualifié pour
le second tour et un autre scrutin
législatif qui vont qui vont suivre ça
peut en partie joue effectivement
puisque on vient de le dire c'est une
force de rappel auprès des électeurs qui
donne ce coup là mais ce parti politique
existe donc il un candidat keller
intéressant donc ça peut avoir un effet
effectivement aux élections législatives
je pense que les faits il est plutôt sur
la vie de ce parti aux militants ça
donne le sentiment ça donne l'image
d'une organisation politique qui est
toujours dans la diva dans la dynamique
qui existe qui a des idées à faire
défendre et au fond ça renvoie aux
militants l'image que cette formation
politique bas ça vaut le coup parce
qu'elle a eu un bon candidat parce
qu'elle a fait parler d'elle pendant la
campagne électorale
et puis ça permet aussi éventuellement
est bien de profiler une prochaine
candidature à la présidentielle si un
candidat issu ces petites formations
politiques performe bien il fait une
bonne campagne le soir du vote il a de
bons résultats c'est un encouragement
pour une prochaine candidature
dernière question en deux mots sans
faire trop de projection est-ce que
c'est l'arrêt de mort des deux grands
partis traditionnels en france parti
socialiste et républicain ce qui est
certain c'est qu'ils vont très mal ces
deux organisations politiques et
l'ensemble des partis politiques en
france ne vont pas très bien la
particularité de la france parmi
d'autres pays européens une relative
faiblesse des partis politiques en
france le nombre d'adhérents ne sont pas
extrêmement élevé les plus grands
mouvements politiques en france sont en
dessous de 500 mille adhérents ce qui
dans beaucoup d'autres pays européens
représentent une jauge assez basse donc
on a un problème structurel en france
qui est de revitaliser la vie
démocratique à travers les partis
politiques et là on veut dire que l'acte
de décès d'un parti politique ne doit
jamais être trop
prononcée trop tôt les formations
politiques ont une grande capacité de
résidence à condition évidemment qu'il
fasse apparaître de nouvelles idées peut
être des fois un nouveau casting et
aussi éventuellement des changements
dans leur dénomination et dans leurs
axes stratégiques merci beaucoup à bruno
cautrès premier tour de la
présidentielle en france dans six jours
bonne journée à vous et merci pour cette
analyse on se retrouve juste après la
pause avec d'abord un coquet